你作为一个正常人，
你明知道这个男的精神有问题，
你还跟他生孩子，
你有没有考虑过万一孩子继承他精神的问题，
你对得起孩子吗？
那我老公现在跟我说说是原因是处于这个离婚的，
我们已经忘已经办到这儿了，
是对对，
我们已经办到这儿了，
我们是在结婚了之后不久，
然后他就精神方面就出了一点问题，
我们去治疗了，
治疗了之后人恢复正常的生活和工作，
就是要吃药，
在这期间，
然后我们又呃有了孩子，
现在是5岁，
然后在孩子不到一岁的时候，
疫情刚爆发，
环境的变化对他病情也有影响，
所以那时候可能他的病情有一点点加重，
然后就因为自己产生的幻想，
就去把别人给伤着了，
然后我们的家里面主动去给别人谈赔偿，
加上医药费，
还有我们赔付给别人的钱接近30个左右，
然后就因为这笔钱就给我们家里面造成了很大的负担，
然后就是在前几年，
我们都是一边工作带孩子，
然后他的父母也帮我还一部分，
他的父母还的是还了十几个，
他们还的多一点，
然后就现在的话，
我们是把亲子钱都已经还完了，
可是就在前段时间，
我父亲去世了，
父亲因为呃，
因为脑梗去世了，
然后在这期间的话，
都是我和我妈妈在，
就是跑前跑后，
包括医院还有家里面的事情，
呃，
照顾我父亲都是我和我妈妈在处理的，
然后她的话，
作为女婿的这个身份，
但是做的是不合格的，
没有做到，
就是像我们想的那样，
去帮我们称一称，
都是我和我妈妈在，
我爸爸在那个。
生监护室的时候，
他也曾告诉我，
他觉得父亲那个样子他心里面也很难受，
他没办法去承担这份压力，
他就给我很去关心，
我没关心，
我和我妈妈甚至去看一看我的父亲，
他也去过，
就是很少没有达到我们期望的那样。
在这期间有一天我们去看父亲，
回来了之后，
我妈就发现他在有小孩，
就发现当很开心，
我妈妈就说他反正就不开心嘛，
两个就闹得不开心，
后面的话，
我爸爸是6月7号就是走了嘛，
走了之后现在我们的家庭关系就比较紧张，
我妈妈是对他是很生气的，
然后我和他的关系的话，
我也觉得他给不了我什么情感上的支持，
然后孩子的话一直都是我带，
然后他妈妈有时候会帮我带一下，
我是想想和他分开，
可是我又考虑到我孩子，
孩子还那么小，
他也不是说不爱孩子，
可是我就不知道怎么去处理和他的关系，
还有他和我妈的关系，
现在我是和我的儿子在我妈这边住的，
他有时候也会来看孩子，
我就不知道我这个情况该怎么处理，
你明明都已经跟他有那个离什么什么婚证了，
你明明知道他精神上是有问题的，
你还会以跟他一起生孩子了，
我们是有了孩子之后，
因为某些原因才办了这个证，
你什么时候知道他精神有问题吧？
在我们结婚的一年一年左右的时间，
那个时候没生孩子吗？
没有没有，
没有，
你作为一个正常人，
你明知道这个男的精神有问题，
你还跟他生孩子，
你有没有考虑过万一孩子继承他精神的问题啊，
你对得起孩子吗？
因为当时我们问过医生，
他说不会影响。
而且。
但是治疗的话，
他也已经能正常的工作和生活了，
后面我们才决定要的孩子，
你现在想要龙飞帮你解决的问题是什么？
我现在想罗菲姐的建议是，
我是跟他分开好，
还是为了孩子继续跟他在一起，
我觉得你是为了孩子跟他分开这个逻辑才对，
嗯，
对不起啊，
因为从我的这个角度来说的话，
我觉得精神上有问题的人，
那对我的孩子是一个定时炸弹，
我不知道他什么时候会发病，
我不知道他什么时候会暴躁，
我不知道他什么时候会触发他那个精神不正常的那个点，
就像上一次伤害了别人还得赔30万，
那好，
我问你，
他有没有可能精神崩溃的时候生了孩子，
我闺女是，
他虽然生病了，
可是她这么多年她没有生过，
我没有怎么生过孩子，
她没有对孩子那样，
其实她本身是一个很善良的人，
她现在的话就是在吃药，
但是我们去医院看的话，
医生也没有明确说她就是什么症，
是双效或者是是怎么样的，
呃，
我上次也是问医生，
医生就说他是一种焦虑的状态，
就是吃药，
就是把他的一个情绪稳定在一个正常的水平，
他是可以工作和生活的，
你现在跟他没有结婚证，
对不对，
对。
啊，
你现在在没有结婚证的话，
你是自由的啊，
你想怎么样都可以，
因为你们没有夫妻的法律关系，
明白吗？
但是千万不要轻易的去领那张就是复婚啊什么的啊，
但现在这个状态的话，
就是你是分没常好子都是自由的啊，
我现在是在我们呃一个小县城里面50体制内的，
当时也是考虑到因为他那个状态会影响到我考公，
所以加上这个原因，
还有其他一些原因，
我们就去呃办了那个证啊，
然后孩子也是跟着我的，
如果你明明知道他精神上是有问题的，
那你就不要有，
不要以一个健康人的标准去要求他，
不要以一个正常人的标准去期待他，
你不要期待他会在你的父亲去世的时候，
在你的父亲干嘛干嘛的时候，
他会怎么怎么样，
因为他任何时候都有一个借口在那摆着，
他经常有问题啊，
你怎么能要求他跟正常人一样呢？
你怎么能要要求他，
呃，
懂得这些人情世故呢？
好吧，
我要怎么去处理他和孩子之间的关系，
因为家里面发生了这么多事情，
有时候我也会和他吵架，
孩子现在也是跟着我和我妈就那，
所以现在孩子有时候就会很抵触他啊，
现在这个状态就很好呀，
你看孩子跟你妈妈生活在一起，
现在这个状态就已经很好了，
孩子抵触他只是孩子的一种本能，
你不可能说因为孩子不喜欢他，
然后你非得让孩子去喜欢他了，
你也没有这样的能力啊，
对不对？
可是以我会想，
这样对孩子是不是不公平啊，
其实我剥夺了他父亲对他的关心，
还有他父亲对他的陪伴一样，
你没有故意的去剥夺就可以了，
本来你们就没有夫妻的法律关系了，
本来你们现在分开住就是合情合理的，
本来当时签协议的时候也是孩子归你，
你现在没有做错任何事情啊，
我就是一直有感觉，
只要他呃好好的配合治疗，
他会好起来，
就一直在自己的脑海里面，
就幻想都能有一个正常的生活，
能够给孩子一个温暖的家，
我就感觉我对孩子很愧疚，
你对孩子愧疚是因为你选择跟这个男人生孩子，
你就是亏欠孩子的，
你现在需要做的是我怎么才能保证孩子在一个没有危险的，
没有精神压迫的，
没有任何精神类的这种风险的状态下让他长大，
这才是对孩子的弥补是就我现在的话，
就好好的好好带孩恋爱，
好好的陪伴孩子，
自己好好的工作他。
孩子在一个没有任何这种来自精神方面的风险的状态下去健康成长就好了啊，
要激怒你的这个孩子的爸爸，
不要跟他关系搞得太僵，
就慢慢的缓和的，
平淡的，
让他和你们的生活有一定的这个距离就好了，
有一定的界限就好了。
嗯，
那我需不需要和他好好商量的说，
就是我们呃，
彻底分开，
然后他每个月给我抚养费，
然后我自己带孩子，
可是我也不会剥夺说他不来看望孩子或者怎么样的，
可以这样做吗？
我觉得现在你们这个状态就已经很好了，
你再等他适应一段时间，
他自己过得挺好，
他自己过得挺开心，
他没有什么痛苦的状态下的时候，
哎，
有可能跟他商量这个事情，
我也常常在想我自己原生家庭的问题，
或者是缺爱吧，
所以我就很很想拥有一个嗯原满的家庭，
然后给孩子呃，
一个充满爱的一个家庭环境，
所以才会和他在一起，
还有了孩子，
我老是觉得生活会慢慢变好的，
会的，
你就带着孩子好好过啊，
自己带着孩子好好过，
你有这个经济能力啊，
自己有稳定的工作，
孩子只要是经健康康的你，
你带着孩子过，
生活也会慢慢变好的，
嗯呃，
本来也想过，
你就是和他缓和关系了之后，
我就带着孩子过，
我怕我以后万一我有了新的生活，
我怕他会刺激到他，
然后会反过来伤害我和孩子，
那你就不要轻易的不要着急的有新的生活，
你等他那头有了新的生活再说，
等他那头都谈恋爱。
是吧，
他那头人家就就都已经跟别人都好上了，
再说好的好的，
谢谢刘贝女士，
嗯，
再见啊，
我一再强调，
你们选择伴侣的时候，
一定要选择什么身体健康心理健康的人，
因为我们都不是专业的人士，
虽然说他生病了也不是他的错，
但他生病不是我导致的，
我没有这个理由拿我的后半生的安全和幸福来作为赌注去拯救任何一个人，
因为他们的生病不是我的责任，
不是我导致的。
姐妹们，
你们什么时候才能明白这个道理？
千万不要觉得你是什么圣母，
你能拯救谁，
你能挽回谁啊，
咱们不是专业的人。
专业的事儿交给专业的人去干，
比如说心理咨询师啊，
穿白大褂的呀，
那些啊，
就是有能力的呀，
人家干这个，
我们只是普普通通的人，
我们在选择伴侣的时候，
一定要选择身体健康的，
心理健康的啊，
否则的话，
你就是第一对自己的人生不负责任，
第二对孩子的人生不责任，
第三你该我，
我没有针对刚才连麦那个妹妹的意思啊，
我针对的是所有的正在选择伴侣的姐妹，
我刚刚这三句话是针对的是你们，
如果你们不听龙飞姐的话，
非要扮演一个拯救者，
非要去找那种精神上有问题的，
你觉得你能改爸爸的话，
你该正在选择伴侣的人，
如果你发现她精神上有问题，
心理上有问题，
如果你还抱着一种拯救她的姿态去的话，
我只能说啊，
你的选择，
今天的选择就注定了你的苦难。